even though i know people are going to
come at me sideways online it is reality
tv and they're obviously only going to
show
what is going to stir the pot the player
we have cited to block
is
no
oh come on i already know i'm blocked
you don't have to tell me
well congrats on the circle i have to be
honest i was very curious if lightning
could strike twice with this show and
i'm so
glad to say that it has it was so fun to
watch um
thanks in big part to you and tara
alicia
well i'm glad i could be entertaining
for you did you watch the last season of
the
us circle and what did you learn from
watching it that you took into going
into the show
right that's actually the entire reason
why i did the show i was such a huge fan
in the first season everyone was in
quarantine i was looking for new shows
to binge watch and
the circle came up on you know my
netflix speed
and i could not stop watching it and i
saw so many opportunities
in the first season from game play and
strategy that i could implement
and that's ultimately what led me to
apply for the circle
did you speak to anyone before you went
on did you talk to
joey or sammy or chris or anybody i
wanted to so
badly but also i wanted to go in and
play a fair game as far as possible
even though i did want to implement a
lot of strategy and gameplay
i am friends with sammy from season one
uh but i did not reach out to her until
after i did the show
i wonder because like you know in
previous seasons they had never really
been in like a quarantine where they
can't really see anyone
that's how we've been communicating with
everybody for the last year do you feel
like it almost like prepared you for
this experience
you know what i'm gonna be honest with
you i thought so
but i could not have been more wrong i
mean the circle
does have its quarantine aspects but
there is nothing
quite like having 20 cameras on you
all the time filming everything from
you brushing your teeth to using the
bathroom to sleeping
it's a little creepy how much down time
did you have versus like
when you're actively playing the game
and what did you do to occupy yourself
because
don't they let you like bring like a
thing with you
yeah i mean to be honest you don't have
as much
time as it seems there's so much that
actually happens in the game so many
different conversations that you're
having
there's no way that the circle could
keep
you know all the episodes to be as short
as they were if they were to air
everything
so when you did have the little down
time
that you had at least for me i napped i
was so tired the entire time
i mean i don't know if it was the time
change or
i don't or the weather i think is
manchester is just so gloomy and
it makes me sleepy but yeah
i don't know i i spent almost all my
time
either playing sudoku or sleeping what
surprised you most about how the game
works
i think the part that the biggest
learning curve for me
is figuring out how to
use the show to your advantage you know
ultimately that it's a reality tv show
they want people to be entertaining
that's the whole reason for
reality tv and so finding reasons
to want to talk to other players beyond
oh i just want to get to know them
was i think one of the biggest pieces of
the puzzle that i gave courtney
uh on my departure trust no [ __ ]
you need numbers so you need to make
friends you have to be a sneaky [ __ ]
okay honestly play the game because i
feel like last season
what was so interesting is they were all
just like i don't know they all really
got along but this season we kind of see
this thing that happens where like you
mistranslate like a text
like you're like oh i just i read this
differently than they meant it
so watching it back where you like oh we
were both just like kind of
misinterpreting each other or like
how did you feel like watching it back
absolutely i mean i think
at the time i i knew it as well um that
it was just like a lot of things getting
lost in translation and that's what
happens when you have a game
like the circle and when you're speaking
to each other via text the entire time
you lose people's you know where
they you know have addiction and what
they're stressing what they're not
stressing and so
you're left to wonder you know what
exactly did they mean and am i
perceiving all of this correctly
so do you feel like the drama with tara
alicia was like a
dark cloud on the rest of your
experience i was pretty much over at the
moment that i got blocked from the
circle
you know i can take accountability i
have reached out to her multiple times
since the show has come out and we have
reached a resolution since then
um just expressing you know that my
apologies
telling her that even though i'm not
sorry for what i said because
and from my perspective i wasn't lying
um i am sorry for how i said it
and you know even though uh
you know i said what i said i will take
accountability for
how my words affect people and how they
affected her and so i made myself very
clear to her
and um i'm really happy with the place
that we're in right now and we're
cordial and that's all that i can ask
for
and i even told her um recently you know
that she reminds me so much of of
my mom and i mean this in the nicest way
possible my mom and i
growing up you know sometimes we would
butt heads but it was because we were so
similar and i said the same thing to
tear alicia you know i can tell
that you are a strong smart educated
young woman
and i don't think that you would be
fighting
me back this tough if you really felt
that you were in the wrong and so i feel
like we just have to agree to disagree
we both have our own truths you know and
watching it back now we can definitely
see each other's perspective a little
more
um so yeah hopefully there
is a friendship blossoming there but i'm
also not gonna be
hurt if there isn't i have a lot of
friends so looking back on the
experience what's one thing that you
wish you did differently
oh that's a hard one you know with these
experiences especially it's so easy
to watch it back and say oh i would have
done a b and c differently you know if i
knew then
what i do now but honestly
maybe i don't know it's so hard like
maybe i would have been a little more
clear with the girls from the beginning
as to why i saved trevor and why i
didn't save chloe i mean
it didn't show it in the show but right
before i
saved trevor i said with taralisha and i
both being
both influencers i don't think i need to
explicitly
save chloe because one it would show all
the guys that
we have an alliance and one of the girls
and two
i think it goes without saying that
she's already saved considering two of
the four people
uh she's in an alliance with are are
the ones making the decision um so i
think i would have made myself a little
more clear
at that about that i did think that it
was a little obvious
but apparently it wasn't what's one
thing that you wish that people knew
about you
oh um gosh that's so hard
i mean i feel like no matter what people
know or what they search online they
don't really ever
know the real you um i i wish
people i guess knew that i was like a
very level dependent person and that i
really thought through every decision
and
even though i know people are going to
come at me sideways online for saving
trevor and not chloe
that there was a real reason behind
everything and
to remember that it is reality tv and
they're obviously only going to show
what is going to stir the pot